so here I am right here at the World
Economic Forum in Davos Switzerland it's
my first time and I'm in good company
it's the first time for president
Hollande and Prime Minister Renzi and
I'm going to take you behind the scenes
come to Davos they said rub shoulders
with world leaders billionaires and
central bankers all I've met so far
security guards and freezing cold
temperatures and it really ain't that
glamorous now I'm in the world-famous
conference centre supposedly this is
where the magic happens and where the
deals get done there he is
so I can't see governor Kuroda I can't
see jack Kumar I can't even see Pharrell
Williams what I can see a lots and lots
of cameras to be fair it is opening
night and it is starting to fill up but
this is not quite my crowd these guys
are here to see the opera singer Andrea
Bocelli I say we tear up the script and
do something a little bit different
let's face it the real networking isn't
done at the Congress centre it's done
right here at the bar my challenge now
is to find myself one of those notorious
Davos parties